(rock music)
- Hey, everyone.
My name is Jesse from
the BuzzFeed food team
and today I'm gonna be cooking up
four famous celebrity pancake recipes
to see which one is actually the best.
I have recipes lined
up from Gordon Ramsey,
Ina Garten, Chrissy Teigen,
and for a little bit of fun,
I even have a recipe from The Rock.
I measure all the ingredients precisely
to make everything fair.
I picked my winner but I
got three of my friends
to pick their winners
in a blind taste test
to see which one is actually the best.
So, let's get cooking.
Gordon gets all fancy and
separates his egg whites
from the yolks and whips them until foamy.
This is just to incorporate
air into the pancakes
to make them nice and fluffy.
And he must be cooking for a crowd,
because he used an entire liter of milk,
eight teaspoons of baking
powder, and 640 grams of flour,
which, if you're not familiar,
is a shit ton of flour.
After that, he mixes all
the remaining ingredients
together in a separate bowl,
he folds the whites back into that mixture
and that batter is good to go.
(upbeat pop music)
He cooks them in a buttered
skillet until browned
but no lamb sauce this time.
(upbeat pop music)
- I feel like these celebrities
have their coloration
of pancakes down, pack.
- A little thinner than I am used to.
- Mmm.
- They missed a few ingredients.
- I love it!
It's like Sunday morning.
- These are Gordon Ramsay's?
I would expect any recipe of
his to be pretty top notch,
and I have to say that these were.
- [Jesse] Up next is Ina Garten's recipe
for Banana Sour Cream Pancakes.
She starts by sifting all
her dry ingredients together
in one bowl and mixes all her
wet ingredients in another.
This includes eggs,
lemon zest, good vanilla,
her secret ingredient,
sour cream, then milk.
She stirs that until
smooth then adds that back
into her dry mixture and
mixes that up until smooth.
She heats up a skillet with
butter, adds the batter to that,
and tops each pancake with one
tablespoon of diced bananas.
Flip 'em, then serve them with
butter, even more bananas,
and garnish with maple syrup.
- Ohh, these look like
Instagramable brunch pancakes,
that you pay like $20 for.
- Mmm, never had banana pancakes before
but this tastes like banana
pudding for breakfast.
- But it's like nah.
- The banana provides
an interesting contrast
in taste and texture which is really nice.
- Whoever made this is heaven sent.
- I'm so disappointed in myself,
I wish I liked this more.
- [Jesse] Up next is Chrissy Teigen
with a recipe for her Dutch Baby Pancake.
Chrissy goes super simple
and just dumps everything
straight into a blender
to make her batter.
She blends it up until smooth
and then dumps it directly into
a heated, cast iron skillet
with two tablespoons of butter.
She transfers that to an oven,
let's it bake for about 17 minutes,
and it comes out looking like this
crazy, crackly weird looking thing
and she finishes it with
butter, maple syrup,
and a generous dousing of powdered sugar.
So, Chrissy must have a sweet tooth.
- It looks kind of like an elephant ear.
- If you look at it,
it looks like almost like
gelatinous in the middle.
- This is like a french toast pancake.
- You can taste a lot of egg in it,
which I'm not used to in pancakes,
it's not necessarily a bad thing,
it's just really different.
This is Chrissy Teigen, okay.
- I like it, I love it.
- [Jesse] Dwayne The Rock Johnson
uses traditional pancake mix.
He posted his video on Instagram
so I tried to mimic it
as closely as possible.
He adds milk chocolate
chips, not semi-sweet,
as he explained that sweet chocolate
was his nickname at University of Miami.
He cooks them on a stove top, flips 'em,
and, as if chocolate
isn't enough for this guy,
he finishes them with maple
syrup and whipped cream.
This would certainly make
the perfect cheat day meal.
- So these look like
IHOP birthday pancakes.
- This is really good.
- This is it.
This is the shit.
This is my jam.
The chocolate chips are like
super gooey on the inside,
the dough is perfect, it's not too eggy.
- These are The Rock's pancakes.
I smell what The Rock is cooking.
- I'm so ashamed!
(laughing loudly)
Whatever, I have low
brow taste I admit it.
(hard rock music)
My favorite celebrity
pancake recipe is The Rock's,
and, honestly, it's because
his has chocolate chips,
that's it.
- I would say my favorite of
the celebrity pancake recipes
was Ina Garten's.
Her's had a really great
taste with the bananas
and also the bananas in
the pancakes themselves
provided a nice change in texture.
- My favorite celebrity
recipe is definitely The Rock,
I mean, I don't know
how this fluffy monster
made this beautiful combination,
but I think it has the
right amount of chocolate,
it has the right amount of pancake,
and it has the right amount of sweetness,
and it's still fluffy which is dope.
(victorious music)
- [Jesse] So, it turns out,
The Rock has the best
celebrity pancake recipe.
(loudly burps)
- So sorry, so sorry.
Damn, those pancakes were good!
- [Jesse] Which celebrity
recipe do you want to see next?
Let us know in the comments below.
(energetic music)